[Music]
you recently changed your phone number
you did you change their phone number
because I went to call you and I could
not get through and you change your
phone number and I took it personally at
first we'll others had the new number
but that's not the no I I mean I I don't
understand the telemarketer thing and it
seems like so ridiculously should be a
lot so I for in six months I had to
change it twice and I just changed it
again and about three weeks ago I got a
call and it's like telemarketer so I
hang up and then oh I can do sound
effects - yeah that's a really old your
phone ya prick and I hanged up over
bloah my relevant bass [ __ ] you know
you're a good swear yeah yeah and the
third one is you know prick or prick
because I was doing some thinking yeah
yeah so I say to my daughter who's you
know seven Noahide she's that guy I say
to my daughter Catherine I say okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna have a heart attack you
get that and she goes to the phone and
she says oh I'm sorry have you been
phoning for the last three times here
oh I'm sorry okay I'll get my dad dad at
Steven Spielberg he's used to it